Let's get started with
the serial version.
First of all, we have the three
ID actions, synchronousDownload,
this is the first button,
simpleasynchronousDownload,
this is the second button.
And asynchronousDownload.
This is the one that will
use completion block.
So let's get started
with a synchronous one.
And we need to do four steps.
These are the four steps that we need
in order to download this image.
So first of all,
we need to get the URL for the image.
Then once we have the URL, we will need
to obtain the NS data for the image.
And we don't really care for NS data.
What we really need is a UI image.
So we have to turn this
NS data into a UI image.
And finally, we're going to display it.
So, let's just insert the code.
Okay, so this is the source code.
As I said previously,
the first steps you get the URL, and
there is a catch here.
NSURL may return an.
So, this actually won't be a URL,
it's going to be an optional
with a URL inside.
Then, we have to turn
this URL in to a NSdata.
We have to fetch this
image from the URL.
And we're using NS data contents of URL,
which only accepts a URL,
not an optional.
So we have to unwrap it.
Once we have the NS data,
we need to turn this NS data into
something that we can use, a UI image.
Again, just as before,
the method that we're going to use,
does not accept an optional.
So we have to unwrap it.
And provide the NSData.
So, this is not very nice,
what we're doing here.
Having all these unwrapping's.
But I want to have it line by line, so
you can easily spot who's the culprit.
Start thinking who might
block In this code.
And last but not least,
we have to display the image.
So, once you have this code written
down, let's run the simulator,
and make sure if it blocks or not.
It should, and indeed it does.
As you see when I click here,
it should just blink.
Instead, it remains inactive for
a certain time,
while the image is being downloaded.
And while that happens, you can't
do anything, the GUI is blocked and
it's blocked for
a user perceivable amount of time.
So, congratulations you have just
been rejected from the app store.
We cannot deliver code that behaves
like this, under no circumstances.
Fortunately, after all the wax on,
wax off of the last lesson,
we now have all the tools to fix this.
However, before we do it in the next
video, see if you can refactor this
code, and put everything inside
of a single if let statement.
It is not good practice to have all
these exclamation points into your
Swift code.
And besides, it's also unsafe.
So, before you move on
try to refactor this.
Put it into a single if let statement,
and we'll continue on the next video.